all right let's see what should the [ __ ]
up hey I'm Zack and today I'm taking a
bath in champagne to see if I can get
drunk through my skin
why champagne because champagne is the
highest proof alcohol that BuzzFeed's
legal team would allow us to do also I
like bubbles there's not a lot of
research on whether or not you can
absorb alcohol through your skin so
we're gonna do this for you or science
I've got some friends here to help put
champagne on me Keith we got Shane looks
like a nice ear my best friend Ben from
New York Ben is a doctor and has
informed me that I should be concerned
about a UTI because alcohol has sugars
and sugars in your pee pee hole is a bad
time so I've worn a condom and I've
wrapped it with rubber bands the very
confusing day don't zoom in don't do
this don't do that
but first to prove that I am NOT yet
drunk I'm going to take a breathalyzer I
didn't have enough breath well it's
zeros let's just trust that huh let's do
it you mean I didn't take our clothes
off great I am potentially a little
worried I'm mostly just worried that
it's gonna stain but you know it's
Friday so let's party who wants to pour
stuff on me
[Music]
sorry I spit it out I'm not drunk yet
but this is definitely a weird fever
dream I feel great yeah I feel very
relaxed all right let's see what [ __ ]
the [ __ ] why this point oh six three it
says danger
hold on those other items in the
interview it's like beeping danger maybe
your butt chose not exit
no it's in the caution level and there's
a frowny face blinking it's really hard
right now to know if this is a placebo
or real but I definitely I feel a loopy
yeah uh-huh
[Music]
we basically went right now we're trying
to see is the breathalyzer picking up on
me or is it just picking up um it's
O'Keefe is joining me he's good but when
I left the fumes get into my mouth all
right take a take a breathalyzer my
testicles feel tingly 0.39 not oh three
nine either point three top all right so
it's something I'm dead literally drive
I'm dead at this point
oh there are experimentation we found
that anyone who breathalyzers right here
it will read way too high so we're gonna
take Zack get him out his tub douse him
with water so he doesn't have any fumes
on his own body breathalyze them and
that should tell us to pinnate of Lee
maybe not making it bad to shampoo
shaving
I'm really hoping that I'm at least a
little some point Oh - yeah we did in
America it does seem like his body did
absorb some alcohol so what are we
learning today very exciting this is a
definitive piece of scientific
literature from this point forward so I
mean my takeaways here are if you have
$300 and a lot of friends than you two
can barely get tipsy in a bathtub yeah
this is not a very economical way to get
drunk No
[Music]